my whole life people who did not know me
well or only met me once or as that the
gist of me had always said you sound
like cleveland brown and i'm like i do
not sound like cleveland brown at all i
got a little history with that
i actually
was in the 15-minute presentation
that became family guy to fox
then i watched the show and then they
had this black character that was one of
peter's friends i'm like where the hell
that come from
and how come i didn't even get to
audition
because when we recorded that very first
thing there were no other black people
in the room but me and and i was pissed
at first
and it's funny because
you know this is one of those things
that people don't understand
my son's 20s like that's racism it's
like
it's
insensitivity it's ignorance
it's lack of priority and he spun off
the show they should have recast that
then and they knew that